Here we go. All right, so we had some questions that came in. I hope everybody had a great Christmas time.
It's their first after Christmas Zoom call and the last Zoom call of 2018 time flies when you're having fun.
And this was everybody's picture of Christmas cookies, I'm sure, right?
Does everybody stay in other diet as best they could?
You remember you just do the best you can and you don't beat yourself up if you go off of it.
Off your diet a little bit, but everybody does the best they can.
So I want to go through some questions that people had said did had some questions that had raised this just this past week.
So the first one was can I use the right in bed while a child is in bed with you know we get every almost every single person asked the question,
what about my spouse that's in bed with me, are they going to be they're going to be a negative effect on the right with the spouse of the answer is obviously no, it's not.
If we're not running, if you're spouse, if you're running breast cancer, frequencies and frequencies that were specific to you and your spouse doesn't have breast cancer, then it's not going to positively affect them either.
Down there's not going to be any ill effects of the right, there really isn't any ill effects of the right at all.
Unless your spouse or your child in this case has Lyme disease.
So if a person has Lyme disease that you just have to go slow the only ill effect is if you're running kill programs, Lyme kill programs, if you're running Borrelia programs or some other Lyme call infection programs you could kill too quickly.
And the person could have a detox reaction.
Those are not in almost anybody's right programs for cancer patients, they're obviously their right programs if you're a Lyme patient.
And if you're so if you're a Lyme patient and your little child is late in bed with you or your spouse is in bed with you and they also have Lyme, yes, there could be some ill effects.
If you're a cancer patient and the cause of your cancer is not Lyme, you don't have any Lyme frequencies in your program, in your overnight program.
So there is no ill effects. If you have cancer in your child is sleeping in bed with you, even if it's a brand new new board, there is no ill effects for the child.
For your programs for your cancer, for your case, while the child has a bed with you absolutely not.
Two of my children, one has five children, what is six children, use.
So I have 11 grad kids that use the right on a very regular basis and their parents did even with the babies were very very little.
I always say the right is your go to tool for the rest of the family. So even though you have cancer, if your little two year old is coming down with a horrible flu or a virus or a cold, you should be running cold and flu programs on your baby and other people in the household as well.
It should be your go to it's not going to be a panacea for every disease, but it should be your first go to for anything you have coming up.
So if you have a real bad cold, you should be running cold programs on your children or if they have a stomach flu, you should run in flu programs, something like that.
So no, there is no ill effects of using the right with a child in bed. Yes, you can use the right with a child in bed, even a brand new board, even a pregnant mother. So there's no problems with that.
Back in question is there a benefit to taking my supplements at a specific time of the day.
So I thought this was a really good question for a couple of reasons because I brought this up on a camera remember if it was a zoom call or I made a video about this a few months ago.
About taking supplements, just some studies I was doing about taking supplements prior to using the right machines with ties in with that last question.
So what is the right for she doing the right for sheet is hitting cancer cells in a specific frequency.
Well, that can help stimulate the uptake of chemotherapy and specific nutraceutical therapy into the cancer cell and help kill the cancer cell as well.
There can be some benefits to taking supplements right before you do your right time, which would be for the 85% of the people right before you go to bed.
So taking your supplements, especially your cancer killing type supplements like mushrooms or protocell or whatever you're taking for killing the cancer, whatever we have you on taking that die time dose right before you go to bed.
Number two, there could be a huge benefit to breaking supplements up through the day and I've said this over and over again.
All supplements are food based right hopefully most of their food base are their nutraceuticals or firms that have a half life in your body.
That means they will be broken down by your own bodies metabolic activity and utilized in gone pretty soon.
So if I take if I have a habit of taking all my supplements right away when I wake up in the morning and I don't take any supplements the rest of the day and I wait till tomorrow morning to take my supplements again, those supplements are long gone before the end of the day comes about.
So you want to break up supplements as best you can some people are really good at that. Some people use a little app on their phone to read or remind your app so it tells them to take their supplements that helps them remember to take their supplements.
Some people put their supplements in the bathroom so every morning you know when they get up they remember to take their supplements where they brush your teeth they remember to take their supplements where they brush your teeth before they go to bed.
Whatever your habit pattern is however you have your setup it's best to break it up into as many different stages as possible.
Morning lunch and dinner would be great or morning lunch and bedtime would be great but at least morning and bedtime and getting them right before you go to bed can be super beneficial because it can be really beneficial when you have the right running.
So Donna you had a question I'm muted you you can ask your question yes thank you I hope you had a good Christmas thank you.
Now what about the TRE if we take our supplements just before bed then we're eating like in late late late morning maybe early afternoon if we want to try to keep our TRE schedule.
Yep so if you the only thing that I'd say with that would break your TRE is if you're taking if you're taking your green streak.
So is that what you're speaking about is like you're doing your green drink right before you go to bed and that's breaking your.
Breaking your TRE.
No right now I try to have everything done by by by about six o'clock everything I break up my vitamins throughout the day and so I start probably when I have breakfast late in the morning like you know when I'm 30 or 10 and I try to eat no later than five but sometimes it goes to six and then I don't eat or drink anything other than water after that.
So I'm wondering if I took those nutraceuticals before I went to bed is that breaking the TRE.
No no I would say no the only thing that would be breaking your TRE is if you're drinking like a big green shake.
So if one of your nutraceuticals I don't have your file in front of you if one of your nutraceuticals is medicinal mushrooms and you're putting it and you're putting it in a green drink or something like that then yeah you that yes you would be.
So then you might want to take your evening.
If you're trying to get it right before you go to usually the right right before you go to bed like we're talking about it this talk.
You could take the mushrooms in a different form before you go to bed like putting it in a little bit of water shake it up causally to just chase it with some water.
I know it tastes pretty awful.
But if you're if you're not getting a lot of calories in and certainly your supplements don't count for that at all you could take your supplements that does not break your your type restricted eating.
Oh even the hardest supplement.
No not at all yes you could take those.
Right okay all right.
Another question is are there any negatives to taking supplements immediately before doing a soda.
Good question first of all it's a good idea to take minerals before you do a soda especially if you're doing a soda is on a daily basis.
And you really really sweat a lot which is what you want to do in a soda you don't want to be losing too many electrolytes.
But I think there is some huge benefits to taking supplements because one of the question the person asked was why losing all my supplements through sweating while doing a soda no you're not losing any supplements during the sweating.
You are losing some minerals which are electrolytes sweating and you're losing a lot of toxins sweating that's the whole idea of doing a soda.
But the other benefit of doing a soda other than detoxification is that you're creative fever like state by raising your core body tip but you're a couple of degrees of that helps increase circulation.
Which could increase circulation in oxygenation to a tuber which if I have those nutraceuticals running through by veins at that time it could help mobilize nutraceuticals to the tuber site as well.
So I think it could be a great positive to take supplements prior to doing a soda.
So maybe if you want to try to organize your day if you're doing a soda you could do a soda maybe an hour or so before bed you take your supplements prior to the soda you do the soda.
And then you dry off and you get ready for bed and then you're doing the rife I don't know just a thought to organize your day. I don't have a soda simply because I should have time to do it which is sad and sorry comment.
But so those are great they're a great detoxification tool and I think taking supplements prior to soda could be a great idea it makes sense at least to me.
Next question what's your favorite Christmas present you received well my favorite Christmas present received is something that I am going to tonight.
My wife and daughters bought me a tickets to my biz I favorite play and if you do not like labes we don't need to talk anymore I'm just kidding but labes is always been one of my favorite place and going to see that tonight.
So fantastic so we don't have a lot of people in the call but I'm going to unmute you and ask and open it up to questions and see if anybody has any other questions.
Yes I do again I haven't been able to talk to you I hope you have a good time with your play tonight that's wonderful yes.
I have several things got your email on I don't know how to say this when you're losing weight I don't know how you pronounce.
It's called cakecia cakecia still there Donna it lost you all right Donna I lost you I can't hear you I don't know if your mic went out but if you have a question on cakecia.
I will challenge you to go to our YouTube video our YouTube channel and if you look up YouTube doctor Kevin cutters that is our YouTube channel that I have multiple videos of cakecia so if you search down through the videos that you'll be able to see the videos that I have on there you can you can watch those.
Donna you back.
I'm back now thank you I don't know what happened I don't know if you were able to hear me during that time but I said a good thing to do learning about cakecia is go to our YouTube channel or.
If I remember tomorrow with the officer you could email me tomorrow I can have one of the girls search those videos and email you the links to those videos I made several videos on cakecia and some things that you could do for that if you're losing weight.
And give you some ideas how what what's going to tell me a little bit.
Well I do have a my blood work done on last Tuesday all I got back with my CDC I haven't gotten my cancer numbers back yet that was another question that I was going to ask you about.
They weren't as hopeful as I thought they were none of them went out of range but they were the ones that were in range were going in the wrong direction trying to get out of range.
Okay so do you have that blood work that you can email me to.
Yeah I was waiting to get the other blood work before I sent them both to you but yeah I can send that to you.
The hemoglobin went from like 9.4 to 9.5 so it wasn't a big step and I'm just wondering that was another question I was going to have I don't need to have rabbit trail here but about blood and you know fusion because I had several friends that would be willing to donate blood just to get my hemoglobin back up.
So I am all in favor of getting packed red cells or an infusion to pop up your hemoglobin however there you're going to probably have a hard press time to get a doctor to do it unless it gets down to about 7.5.
So it depends that if you have an independent clinic that you're going to that somebody will do that but I know that most hospital standards are that your hemoglobin has to get down to 7 or 7.5 before they'll give you any red blood cells.
Yeah I've had to have some before I think my regular just family doctor would be able to do it he knows where I'm at with it.
Okay good and that could be extremely helpful to do that you could instantly have like twice as much energy so that that could be very helpful so I'm a big favor of doing that.
Okay and then the final question I have is
I lost you again down up we must be having some trouble with your connection there.
So down I'm going to sign off and I'll let you just emailing those questions and we'll try to get back to you tomorrow.
I'll have the girls get connected with you if you don't get a chance to listen to this and don't get back on.
So all right it doesn't look like we have any other questions and we're about time to close out so I will say goodbye to everybody and I hope everybody got exactly what they wanted for Christmas.
Thank you and we will talk next week.